can you say something to the history of
alchemy
a little bit
sure um
it used to be thought
two things one that alchemy
which dates certainly back to the
islamic period in islam
you're talking you know
11th 12th 13th centuries
among islamic natural philosophers and
experimenters
but it used to be thought that um
alchemy which picked up strikingly in
the 15th 16th century 1500s and
thereabouts
was a sort of mystical procedure
involving all sorts of strange notions
and so on and
that's not entirely untrue
but it is substantially untrue in that
alchemists were engaged in what uh
was known as chrysopoeia that is
looking for ways to transform
um
invaluable materials into valuable ones
but in the process of doing so or
attempting to do so
they
learned how to
create complex amalgams of various kinds
they used very elaborate apparatus glass
olympics in which they would use heat to
produce chemical decompositions they
would
write down and observe these
compositions and many of the so-called
really strange-looking alchemical
formulas and statements where they'll
say something like i i can't produce it
but it'll be the soul of mars will
combine with the
this etc etc these
it has been shown are almost all actual
formulas for how to engage in the
production of complex amalgams
and what to do
and by the time of newton
newton was reading the works of a
fellow by the name of starkey who was
actually came from harvard
uh
shortly before
in which um
things had progressed if you will to the
point where the procedure turns into
what historians call chrysopoeia
which basically runs into the notion of
thinking that may these things are made
out of particles
this is the mechanical philosophy can we
engage in processes chemical processes
to rearrange these things
which is not so stupid after all
i mean we do it except we happen to do
it in reactors not in chemical processes
unless of course it had happened that
cold fusion had worked which it didn't
um i uh
well right but um so that's the way
they're thinking about these things
there's a kind of mix and newton engages
extensively
in those sorts of manipulations in fact
more in that than almost anything else
uh
except for his optical investigations if
you look through the latter parts of the
1670s the last five six seven years or
so of that there's more on that than
there is on anything else he's not
working on mechanics he's pretty much
gone pretty far in optics he'll turn
back to optics later on
so optics and alchemy
so what you're saying is isaac newton
liked shiny things
well actually if you go online and look
at what bill newman the professor at
indiana
at bloomington indiana has produced
you'll find the very shiny thing called
the star regulus which newton describes
as having produced according to a
particular way which newman figured out
and was able to do it and it's very
shiny
there you go proves the theorem
you